I still can't even believe that this is
happening because it's something that I
wanted for so long my goal is to become
a world champion one day whenever that
may be
MMA fighter Victoria Lee has died she
was 18 years old
[Music]
Victoria's older sister fellow MMA
fighter Angela Lee announced the sad
news on Instagram she posted this image
along with a touching caption on
December 26 2022 our family experienced
something no family should ever have to
go through it is incredibly difficult to
say this our Victoria passed away
Victoria honestly she is wise Beyond her
years ever since she was little we kind
of called her like an old soul she's
just very very mature for her age Angela
didn't reveal Victoria's cause of death
but did honor her with a lengthy message
writing their family will never be the
same and called Victoria the most
beautiful soul who ever lived that's why
I think she is really well able and
equipped to handle all that comes with
this um Fame and this path that she's
chosen born in Hawaii Victoria grew up
alongside her siblings Angela and
Christian Lee Victoria is so talented
and I cannot wait for you guys to see
what skills she has when she makes her
debut all three kids were trained by
their father mixed martial artist Kenley
in his gym
I wouldn't have made it through without
my mom and dad and I know my family's
all back home watching right now and
oh I'm so grateful for them in September
2020 Victoria signed her first contract
with one championship and the following
year she took home three back-to-back
victories in the ring living up to her
moniker The Prodigy
it's the kind of makeup one of my
brothers and sisters for crying after
they won but
I understand it's so emotional
her authenticity along with her fighting
skills made her a fast fan favorite and
how do you feel I feel amazing I want to
eat a Krispy Kreme donut right now
Victoria graduated from high school last
summer and she was looking forward to
working on her craft I've been training
really hard I'm really focused and
um luckily I have my family to support
me the path that we signed up for is
definitely not easy but if we put in the
work it'll be worth it in the end
foreign
[Music]